[Música]
corea del norte reportó hoy unos 263.000
370 nuevos casos de fiebre es
potencialmente vinculadas al cob y 19 lo
que supone que más de 2 millones de sus
ciudadanos podrían estar infectados
desde que el virus aparentemente empezó
a circular en la hermética nación las
cifras apuntan a una transmisión muy
rápida de este virus en un país en el
que la movilidad geográfica está muy
reducida por las limitaciones que impone
el régimen de kim jong-un y la falta de
infraestructura y a su vez indican una
mortalidad excesivamente baja con al
menos 65 personas fallecidas en
comparación con los países que han
sufrido el embate de esta variante del
comit 19 llamada omicron es que aceptar
las vacunas implicaría abrir las
fronteras al personal a foráneo para así
asesorar a un plan de inoculación a
escala nacional estamos hablando
recordemos en este caso de corea del
norte para ello entonces quiero saludar
a nuestra segunda invitada del día ella
es just a carranza co profesora
asistente en la escuela de asuntos
públicos e internacionales de la
universidad de baltimore esto en eeuu
gracias me gusta por estar con nosotros
en directo américa de france 24
felices mañana de viernes le pregunto
entonces de la situación actual de corea
del norte en cuanto al sistema de salud
buenos días muchas gracias por tenerme
en el programa la situación de corea del
norte está mucho más complicada que
estamos examinando los reportajes que
están saliendo en esta parte del mundo
lo que pasa es que corea del norte no
tiene infraestructura de salud pública
entonces más bien en este momento con
las mascarillas que están siendo
utilizadas dentro de corea del norte
todo está llegando con la ayuda de china
y más bien habían reportado de parte de
corea del sur que hace dos o tres días
habían llegado un avión de corea del
norte para recibir artículos
médicos de que estaba donando china y
que había llevado todo eso a cambian
y eso es una situación que indica que la
situación de la pandemia dentro de corea
del norte está muy mal hablando de las
vacunas ya que me está preguntando sobre
la infraestructura de la salud ellos no
tienen la refrigeración especial que
requeriría como vacunas de facer o
modernas
entonces si si pueden aceptar algún tipo
de vacuna ayuda en ese momento lo que si
podrían utilizar serían los de chance si
son sus pero no de otros tipos no ésta
podría digamos en esta situación tan
grave en cuanto al sistema de salud y en
cuanto ya el reporte de cubit de 19 de
la llegada pues de este virus al
territorio norcoreano podría entonces
darse esta apertura del régimen de kim
jong-un para recibir este medicamente
teniendo en cuenta que está jugando con
la vida de su población y ya son más de
2 millones de personas además
que
ha mencionado algo muy importante un
país helvético no es un país muy
clausurado y desde antes kim jong y su
padre también y su abuelo también
siempre han enfatizado tener el control
sobre la población entonces el poder eso
es lo más importante entonces ahora
aunque tienen la pandemia y la situación
está muy grave y muchos dudan obviamente
de los números que está saliendo de 65
muertes probablemente no es la verdad
porque sean más sucesos muy mucho más
graves en otros países mucho más
desarrollados entonces ya se sospecha
que esos números ya no son creíbles
pero lo del poder de kim jong-un es
importante porque necesita bueno afirmar
confirmar que pueda continuar dentro del
país como el jefe mayor la persona que
no va a hacer ninguna manera de local y
para eso él para tristemente también
jugar con la vida de esos
ciudadanas y en realidad es una
situación muy difícil pero lo que sí van
a poder aceptar creo que yo no van a
tratar de aceptar la vida que está
ofreciendo corea del sur por parte del
presidente y un sayón pero probablemente
si china ofrece algo
puede ser que ahí habrá un tipo de
apertura pero no no es una apertura así
porque los dos países desean que se ha
llevado bien no entonces no es una
apertura
demasiada pero al mismo tiempo es
suficiente para equipo como pueda
continuar manteniendo el poder es
también conviene a china y eso es
relacionado a la elegancia que continúa
de la tierra fría niuska y porque no
está perdón porque decirlo ahora no este
régimen de kim de kim jong-un que tiene
kobe 19 porque digamos poniendo un poco
en contexto y viéndolo desde afuera ya
tenemos más de dos años y medio con la
pandemia de kobe 19 apenas ahora algunas
semanas atrás anunció que efectivamente
el virus ya estaba en el país pero en
términos científicos digamos que no
había posibilidad antes de que en dos
años de pandemia este virus haya entrado
antes digamos que la situación si puede
ser mucho más grave en cuanto a kim
jong-un dijo ya se ve que entre la
espada y la pared y dijo ya tengo que
decir que tengo como 19 a ver qué tipo
de ayudas puedo recibir porque imposible
también digamos científicamente usted me
corregirá quién años y medio de pandemia
y nunca haya tenido un solo caso de
cubit no está a punto de estar todas
esas situaciones porque es verdad
entonces años y medio como que no han
podido tener por lo menos un caso d
tienen razón pero lo que pasa es que
esto no y ese punto se también está
mencionando lo que corea del norte ahora
está diciendo y aceptando y el
reconocimiento y reconociendo
oficialmente que tienen obi esto es una
señal que están haciendo al mundo
exterior para que si estamos dispuestos
para poder aceptar algún tipo de aire
porque la situación está mucho más grave
de lo que está siendo reportado o los
números que ellos están dando a base de
su gobierno diciendo que tienen como 2
millones de infectados probablemente la
situación sería mucho más grave pero
están dando esos pequeños signos para
solamente ver si hay posibilidad de
aceptar algún tipo de ayuda del
extranjero pero como dije antes
probablemente aceptarían la ayuda de
parte de china o de parte de thomson
pero no necesariamente de parte de corea
del sur y eso es relación
y su relación generalmente con los
partidos conservadores de parte de corea
del sur que nos lleva también corea del
norte entonces esos otros tipos de
mecanismos políticos que osó políticos
que también entra en las calcula ciones
de kim jong y tristemente los que van a
sufrir va a ser la población de corea
del norte claro está y digamos que rusia
podría hacer algo también para poder
ayudar a la población de corea del norte
eso es importante no te sean de siempre
hemos pensado
periodos de la tierra de corea de
1950-53 y después la importancia de
rusia con a como dijo no se queda el
asesoramiento esto y otro pero en
realidad ahorita los países que de
verdad están más cercanos a corea del
norte virgilios eso no china entonces
china es el que tiene más poder a
comparación con rusia que en este
momento ellos también están enfrentando
otra situación en otra parte de europa
entonces no sería su prioridad no corea
del norte no sería la prioridad más bien
china tiene mucho más control e
influencia en el contexto de corea del
norte